[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv soixante dix huit pour
ce nouvel entretien politique comme
chaque semaine nous allons la rencontre
des maires du département des yvelines
aujourd'hui karl olive première édile de
poissy est avec nous bonjour karl olive
bonjour monsieur ritchie élu depuis 2014
réélection dès le premier tour en 2020
début de mandat forcément très différent
du premier très particulier gestion de
crise sans précédent un an après le
début du premier confinement vous avez
encore besoin d'adapter votre action est
ce qu'il y avait d'autres réponses qui
se met en place
ou est-ce qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement
tout roule et c'est un peu une routine
cette gestion de crise or c'est
exactement l'inversé tous c'est
absolument pas une routine c'est
évidemment le contraire on a vous l'avez
rappelé à juste titre et est élu au
premier tour c'était le 15 mars on est
presque à un an et on a l'impression que
c'est peut-être le lierre temps
finalement la vie normale s'est arrêtée
dès le 16
elles 15 mars ce soir on est ici dans ce
bureau où il faut défier edel 16 ont
préparé le confinement qui se mettait en
place le 17 et à partir du 17 mars 7
jours sur 7 e on et quelques 250
collègues agents à s'être retrouvés
quasiment 7 jours sur 7 sur les 854 du
compte la collectivité donc vous le
voyez on n'a pas le temps et c'est je
crois un très bon exemple d'engagement
que peut être amer de terrain les
fantassins que nous sommes de la
république de montrer que c'est
justement quand nous avons ces
difficultés alors pour le coup
historique atypique que nous sommes
attendus pour bien montrer à nos
administrés que nous sommes là plus que
jamais à leur service il a fallu prendre
le relais de l'état aussi sur le
dépistage sur la vaccination est ce que
vous avez là aussi le sentiment d'avoir
été d'avoir était seul ou accompagné par
l'état justement d'abord pour tout vous
dire on s'est pas vraiment posé cette
question avec avec les collègues et lui
je crois qu'on peut pas tout attendre de
l'état c'était le quai dédié à qui nous
présente lui qui disait que ce ne pas se
demander ce que les
après faire pour nous parce que nous
pouvions faire pour notre pays et en
l'occurrence pour d'autres collectivités
nous très vite ici on sait peu on s'est
organisé d'abord pour sécuriser tout ce
que nous pouvions sécurisé très vite on
a par exemple décidé d'acheter des
masques et on l'a décidé d'acheter des
masques français fabriqué en france pour
sauver l'emploi invitons à activer
quelque chose qui s'appelle la réserve
citoyenne et communales il ya quelques
200 propre bénévoles 17-15 et épicé
lequel ils se sont dit au service de nos
populations
très vite j'ai souhaité que tous les
jours on puisse contacter ces personnes
isolées
vous savez c'est les personnes
vulnérables nous aider on a passé
quelques 12000 à peine en quelques en
quelque trois mois et puis après c'est
vrai que nous nous sommes appuyés sur la
relation nous avions avec le préfet d
évident jean jacques brot était un
élément très important lorsque nous
avons mise en place à la fois pour
souvenez vous ouvrir le centre scolaire
ronsard pour les enfants des personnels
les soignants et tout s'est bien passé
déjà que la mécanique c'est bien aussi
en route le jour où avec le docteur lê
manh nous avons décidé en 24 heures de
transformer notre centre des faits à
l'époque et on revient presque un an
derrière le bruit à l'époque avec le
centre de diffusion artistique devenu
centre de consultation puis juan octobre
un centre de dépistage puis ou à janvier
un centre de vaccination il n'y a pas
que la question du lac au vide 19 si on
parle de santé parlant des projets de ce
mandat il y avait un projet aussi
c'était la concrétisation d'une maison
médicale sur votre commune par exemple
plusieurs maisons médicales vous avez
raison et elles vont voir le jour
typiquement dans un petit mois
maintenant à l'arrière de l'hôtel de
ville avec et c'est une très belle
nouvelle pour les administrés quatre
nouveaux médecins une maison d médical
qui verra également le jour sur les eaux
de poissy du côté du côté de beauregard
en lieu et place d'un bâtiment qui
aujourd'hui pilotée par le bailleur
social vilogia
mais on a aussi décidé dans le cadre de
notre
engagement local de proposer un plan un
potentiel communal l'un des premiers de
france est là simplement deux ans avec
saint-etienne
aujourd'hui il verra le jour là encore
dans un petit mois il sera piloté par
d'autres adjoints la santé de l'auteur
dont père des trois arches est en
quelque sorte un guichet unique pour
toutes celles et ceux qui sont touchés
directement ou indirectement par à la
maladie que c'est parfois
malheureusement vous avez eu le cancer
il ya des difficultés pour savoir
comment comment s'habiller que manger
comment allait avoir de nouvelles coupes
de cheveux par exemple c'est tout c'est
cet aspect que vous pourrez retrouver
aux trois arches dans un petit mois et
demi et ça je crois que c'est aussi
parce que cette année plus jamais notre
notre années 2000 val d'hérens 2021 sera
placé à la fois et ce souci de la
solidarité
ils ont donné quelques exemples
également moustiques de l'assemblée il
ya des succès des réussites il ya aussi
des difficultés quelquefois poissy
commune de près de 40000 habitants a
aussi été victime ces derniers temps
pour certains quartiers de violence vous
êtes exprimé à ce sujet aujourd'hui on
est la situation et quelles réponses
apporter à ces phénomènes de violence
des plus jeunes envers les forces de
l'ordre le paradoxe de la situation
c'est que les chiffres que nous avons
obtenu la semaine dernière donc c'est
tout frais c'est la première fois que je
communique sur le sujet donc pour vous
hâter les soixante dix huit c'est que la
délinquance en quatre ans a baissé de
27% après si je le vois dans les
différents outils que nous mettons en
place le plan de prévention des risques
durbar la vidéo la vidéo protection et
prévention spécialisée qui qui ont
essayé sur l'ensemble du champ public de
lui de possibles
pourtant vous l'avez dit vous avez
raison nous ne sommes pas un micro
climat et ce que nous voyons en france
en matière de violences urbaines c'est
aussi ce que nous connaissons parfois et
tant mieux je vous dis bien parfois à
titre exceptionnel mesures possibles
la vidéo pouvoir vaut à présent c'est
une une vidéo d'une poignée de jeunes
entre 12 et 17 ans qui n'ont pas trouvé
mieux
de s'en prendre aux policiers alors ce
week end là c'est aux policiers mais il
ya un mois et demi c'était pour une
famille dans un quartier populaire
et puis dans une autre ville des civils
il ya à peu près deux mois c'était pour
un des pompiers
et puis auparavant deux indices
également c'était pour des ambulanciers
donc on voit bien que l'espèce de
recrudescence
j'ai envie d'être conjoncturels depuis
quelques mois maintenant tu retournes et
17 ans pour ces jeunes refusent tout
simplement l'autorité quelqu'elle soit
qu'elles soient parental qu'elle soit et
scolaire qu'elle soit policière et nous
attendons évidemment une réponse ferme
et plus réactives de la part de l'état
et quand je dis l'état plutôt de la part
de la justice parce qu'il est important
que nous envoyons y trouver naissent des
message fort à l'endroit à la voie à la
fois de ces jeunes et encore une fois il
s'agit d'une petite minorité mais
également en direction de l'immense
majorité de notre population qui
souhaite simplement que nous soyons
justes et je crois la justesse et à la
justice sociale
ça veut dire aussi quand vous parlez
d'être ferme d'être ferme envers les
parents parce que vous avez aussi évoqué
une poignée de jeunes de très jeunes qui
refusent l'autorité
oui je pense qu'il faut être juste nommé
ferme pour être juste il faut que tout
le monde connaisse les règles et ici
apprécie tout le monde connaît les
règles
à quoi si nous multiplions les
investissements les aident à l'endroit
des familles des familles quelle qu'elle
soit faut pas stigmatiser tel quartier
populaire plus qu'un autre et
investissons par exemple 400000 euros
chaque année pour permettre aux familles
justement d'avoir un peu plus de de
pouvoir d'achat dont quelques exemples
des boursiers nous avons 60 boursiers
qui bénéficie en tout de quelques 110
milles centimes d'euros chaque année
nous avons également des réductions dans
des clubs de sport dans des clubs
culturels etc
et c'est la moindre des choses c'est que
la contrepartie ce soit le respect de
tout à chacun au quotidien c'est quand
même pas grand chose et j'estime que
celles et ceux qui ne respectent pas
entre guillemets ce contrat gagnant
gagnant
elles n'ont pas à obtenir ces aides qui
sont des aides encore une fois un non
obligatoire qui sont des aides
facultatives
là les deux possibles en place vous
parlez des actions envers les plus
jeunes ce qui nous amène un autre sujet
une de vos passions le football si ce
n'est votre passion et vous lancez
justement elle à didier roustan academy
la rouste ans a calé mais ça va
consister en quoi ça s'adresse aux plus
jeunes avec le consultant sportif bien
évidemment associés oui vous avez raison
wilfrid en fait je crois qu'il ya pas de
grande ou petite idée pour justement
permettre à la jeunesse de le pouvoir se
nourrir quand on est passionné de
culture via nous avons des classes
orchestres nous avons des studios
d'enregistrement qui permet de chanter
vous faire par exemple du théâtre
théâtre amateur au théâtre blanche de
castille évidemment quand on est quand
on est sportif fois ci c'est quarante
mille habitants ces dix mille sportifs
inscrits en compétition ou en loisir
vous savez la venue du paris saint
germain va occasionner mille emplois
pour le football judo et lamballe mais
ces sages une au football et en mai pour
autant évidemment quand on est des
initiatives qui sont dirigés justement
pour ces jeunes collégiens entre 12 et
15 ans qui va être le cas avec la rouste
en académie de de possibles eh bien on
saute sur l'occasion il se trouve que je
suis ami avec lady rose tant que vous
connaissez certainement didier roustan
c'est quelqu'un qui est journalistes de
sportifs en particulier de football et a
commenté nombre du monde nombre
d'heureux 2004 qu'a présenté téléphone à
des moins de 20 ans allez plus de 20 ans
pardon mais didier souhaite vraiment
intervenir auprès de cette classe d'âge
ont ordonné l'amour du journalisme et et
l'amour du terrain également aux biens
d'entre nous n'avons pas commencé comme
comme correspondant mais typiquement
didier roustan varrault au fil des
prochaines semaines permettra à tous ces
jeunes qui rêvent de devenir journaliste
ou qui rêvent de commenter des matches à
pouvoir s'adonner concrètement et ça se
passera à la source qui est notre maison
de quartier où nous mettons en place un
guichet unique pour les jeunes il nous
reste très peu de temps pour conclure
cet entretien juste un mot pour parler
économie aussi on parlait des plus
jeunes des actions vers les plus jeunes
y ait des actions vers le territoire le
bassin économique avec le le pôle
économique dynamique home où en est ce
projet alors dynamique houle c'est la
zone d'activité économique qui jouxte le
technoparc de la ville de presse
ces scènes bâtiment un bâtiment
tertiaire sur dix sept mille cinq cents
mètres carrés le nom de dynamic où il
vient d'un clin d'oeil que nous avons
avec nos amis de pierre masse la ville
jumelle de la ville de poissy hors
d'allemagne qui a une zone d'activités
un musée qui s'appelle qui s'appelle
dynamique où je crois que aujourd'hui
les craintes créateurs de richesse sont
véritablement les entreprises il faut
absolument faire en sorte que les
entreprises puissent être accueillis
dans les meilleures conditions
c'est ce qu'on fait après si on ne fait
pas seul selon va plus vite mais
ensemble on va plus loin on le fait avec
eux le département des yvelines avec la
région ile de france et avec la
communauté urbaine dans paris en paris
seine et oise
merci beaucoup karl olive maire de
poissy d'avoir été avec nous pendant ce
quart d'heure pour évoquer les les
premières actions de ce nouveau mandat
on se retrouve bientôt sur tv soixante
dix huit avec un autre maire du
département
[Musique]